this explosion in the czech republic was
one of a series of mysterious attacks
nato allies have linked to russia in
recent years
so concerned they agreed over the summer
to share evidence of suspected killings
espionage and other malign activity
now in a rare step by all 30 member
states the alliance is pushing back
agreeing to expel what they described as
eight undeclared intelligence officers
from the russia mission to nato in
brussels
two vacant positions also abolished the
russian diplomatic presence half to ten
an alliance official said
nato's policy towards russia remains
consistent we've strengthened our
deterrence and defense in response to
russia's aggressive actions while at the
same time we remain open for a
meaningful dialogue
evidence of this desire by both sides at
least at the united nations general
assembly last month in new york but
anger at what seen as russia's
destabilizing activities inside nato
countries mean even traditional friends
of moscow like italy and hungary agreed
to this diplomatic expulsion this was an
important large russian operation in
brussels which has now been pretty
severely degraded by nato's action so
they may look for action against
individual countries but it's hard to
see what they can do against nato as an
organization
yet some feel attacks like the salisbury
spy poisonings and allegations of
election meddling mean nato should have
acted faster and gone further it's
probably the least that nato could do or
possibly the most that all of the nato
member states could actually agree to
because in order to do this you have to
have every single member of nato on
board
never shy to showcase its overt military
might russia consistently denies any
covert malign activities in other
countries
a senior politician said moscow would
retaliate to the nato move and perhaps
not in kind
debra haines sky news